[Music]
10.8 and this is
a little
[Music]
girl B I love that we have dinner served
in the front of the
clinic
Val and I heard the dinner was served
over here yeah we got some corn can we
have two dozen my treat
absolutely hey what did you find
little may I hold them yeah look how
pretty do you know what caterpillars
become butterflies butterflies right he
wants to be an animal doctor you do yeah
this is a great
start awesome this looks delicious guys
thank you so much take good care of your
caterpillar I could eat a whole supper
with sweet corn well I think you might
be on your
[Music]
way come
here hi he how are you hi Raider are you
hi this is a new baby for you yes it is
well congratulations thank you today we
have Raider who is a senior sharpi who
was just recently adopted from a bad
living situation they're not a super
common breed we don't get to see a lot
of these dogs here we go hi oh my
goodness Sharpie puppies they're born
with all the skin they need to be adult
dogs so as they grow they get a little
less wrinkly because they fill out it's
kind of the opposite of people where we
look real nice and not wrinkly as babies
and then time happens and we get real
wrinkly how are things going with him as
a new pet he's doing really well getting
along with most the other dogs but he's
got some eye drainage oh darn it
buddy oh you are runny OED okay this is
really common in Sharpes cuz they're
like giant wrinkles you see how the
eyelid is completely rolling in and how
those little hairs are just rubbing
right on his eyes he has what we call
entropion in that lower lid
entropion issues and Sharpes are really
really uncomfortable it's like having
sand in your eyes all the time it's
definitely not something you want to
continue to have happening if you think
of the eyelids like a like a window
shade they should come down and the back
of the window shade should be what
touches the eyeball but on his case the
window shades all rolled up and all the
hair is rubbing there that's what should
be normal you can see how much I have to
pull down to get that to roll out
obviously that's pretty uncomfortable
for him so it should really be fixed a
lot of times with older rescue animals
they've really had minimal care or have
suffered some sort of neglect clearly we
need to address these eyes these are so
uncomfortable for him he's a sweet old
grandpa dog and I'm really happy for him
that Ariel found him because now finally
we can provide him with some
relief really the solution for his eyes
is what we call an entropion surgery
where we actually take a little wedge of
tissue from below the lids out and then
we kind of tack that out so it makes
those Lids go straight we remove a
little bit of the window shape so is
that something you think you'd like to
do yes
absolutely I would like to put him on an
oral antibiotic because all of his eye
drainage we have a little bit of
infection there I want that skin
underneath his eyes to be as healthy as
we can because that's where we're going
to do surgery sounds good what do you
think you excited it'll be a whole new
lease on life for him yeah Raider's a
sweetheart I'm not sure what kind of
Life he's had but I just want him to
have the best life moving forward his
face will be a little less wrinkly but
in a good
way you're sure getting fed
[Music]
well hello hi Todd hello doc well you
brought me a box full of cookies or what
here that'd be nice wouldn't it
what is in here there's a little baby
guinea oh guinea hens are so useful
around the farm they eat all the insects
they tick and this is pretty rare cuz I
don't get a lot of guinea hens that come
in as patients so it's going to be a
treat to treat a little guinea hen today
I can see the problem from here it's got
a bad leg doesn't it yes it does going
the wrong way for sure definitely going
backwards I bought a dozen guinea hens
for the grandkids to grow up with and
take care of and my grand so noticed
that one of the legs was turned at a
right angle from the other leg was there
a predator involved that you know of
nope not that I know of I know I know
see that leg is totally going the wrong
way it's not wobbly it's very solid but
I think I better get an x-ray before I
do too much manipulation okay okay okay
anytime we work on a bird it's a
two-person project hey honey okay yeah I
need some help with an x-ray I've got a
guinea does little bird have a name it
will after today I want to name it
Winnie the guinea that leg is doing like
fifth position ballet you have it set
[Music]
mhm the X-ray shows a pretty bleak
picture of what happened
[Music]
here hey how are you pretty good Aaron
cute baby bird it is I Nam this Guinea
Winnie just so you know Winnie that's
all right that's we found an answer for
you too you can definitely see the
normal joint on the other side that's
how that's supposed to look and this one
is a total
dislocation right at the knee joint or
the stifle there's a dislocation I think
what we would like to do is to sedate
her totally under general anesthesia
just with some gas and then she'll
loosen up and we can manipulate these
bones and pull them back into place okay
and then we'll put a little splint on
her leg just to hold everything in place
okay yeah that' be fine all right we'll
give you an update okay thank you guys
thank
[Music]
you there you
go are you ready night let me hear
[Applause]
you all right you ready to sweat a
little I'm always ready to sweat sweat
your meat and potatoes off I got more
meat and potatoes to sweat off than you
do hello Ben Chuck is it okay to come in
there yeah we got a call from Chuck
coddle who is a great client he was a
client of your dad's he's an awesome guy
sounds like you got a problem with a
bull yes I do I got a fight with the
other blll threw him through a fence
over there yikes which takes a little
power to do that snap it in half they
call it bullying for her reason yeah
they
do I've had this bowl approximately 3
years he was a yearling when I bought
him he's one of my bulls that I use for
breeding cows I've never had any problem
like this before ever he's not real lame
yet but he's got a lot of swelling there
in the back end well let's see what kind
of damage he did all right well I see
him is that the
spot wow that's a swelling yikes Chuck
that's huge that's a hip that looks like
a big old swelling it could already be a
big abscess if something poked in there
it could be just a big bruise with a
bunch of blood clots whatever it is it's
full and it's full of pressure if we
don't drain this you know that could
definitely get systemic eventually and
make this bulll really sick if we can
get him better then he should be able to
go breed some cows this year yeah I
think he just heard he gets to breed
cows the first thing we need to do is
get this bull behind the gate so I can
give him a dose of sedative all right
Wilson little poke and then we're going
to make him lay down basically so we can
work on him safely now we'll open it up
and let him go to sleep and I'll walk
out of here sweet dreams Wilson we've
got to have him fall so his big lump is
up sometimes these Bulls just need a
little bit of help to fall on the right
side so I want to put a rope around his
left leg pull it underneath him and that
should get him to fall in the correct
position oh I see you're going to help
him yeah I think there's like a ninja
move like that like the leg
sweep so you're a bow ninja sure oh
always have
been oh there we go it's kind of way you
wanted it right that's perfect you don't
happen to have a a sweatshirt or a coat
or something in your truck do you let's
put that over his head so he can't see
what we're doing stay down cover him up
yep cover up his
[Music]
head this is the bottom of the swelling
Chuck so this is where we're going to
want to make our incision that's a
bruise I think see all that dark that's
a big old bruise also known as a
hematoma what do you always call him a
hemat tomata a hemat tomata this one's
like a he watermelon a he prize winning
pumpkin we've got to find out what is in
this huge swelling the best way to do
that is to First insert a needle and see
what kind of fluid is in
there oh yeah bloody he sprung a leak
this is a big old suroma a saroma is
really a big pocket of serum and it's
usually caused by really really hard
blunt force trauma which is exactly what
this bull had happened to him so we want
to make a Nick in it with a scalpel and
just make a nice a drain hole for it
yeah I'm really hoping that draining
this will do the job but who knows what
else is in here here we
go oh
boy oh wow wow it's got to feel better
though oh yeah we got to it right before
it turned into puss yep there's some
blood there's some serum there's blood
clots there's fibrin clots which is the
body's way to try to close this all back
up and make everything go together I've
never have had any been like this before
you've been doing this a long time Chuck
I Haven had that problem Chuck this
would potentially cause death oh I'm
sure it would yeah he kind of had a
mixture of a seroma and a hematoma all
at once and if you wait long enough that
can become an abscess but chuck had us
out here in a timely manner if you would
have let this turn into an abscess and
potentially get systemic throughout the
bulll this bulll could be dead so this
was the perfect time to get this drained
get it out of his system and let him
heal up so you don't have to go all the
way up in there to get it all out or you
cuz I made my cut at the bottom of it
yeah it'll drain okay I would say at
least two basketballs worth of fluid in
there look at that yeah now that we've
got it lanced we've got a majority of
the clots out we need to treat this bowl
with some antibiotics flush that wound
out the best we can give him some pain
medication and then wake him up he's a
big bull and he needs to be up on his
feet here ASAP I think it's time to wake
him up y I think he's ready to get up
good boy morning Wilson come on Wilson
I'm going to leave this incision open to
drain cuz if I were to suture it up it
would trap all that infection in we want
it out not in the body feel like he kind
of looks like you getting out of bed in
the morning
Ben there we go come on there oh yeah
there we go there go right out the door
that way now don't
fall oh now you think they'll pick on
him uhoh get out of here get over there
we've got to get Wilson from our pen to
the other pen without the other Bulls
really being bullies again he's looking
at you Ben get over there with your
buddy they know that he's a little bit
weakened he's a little bit sedated so
we've kind of got to play keep away
come on Wilson heads up head up he's
squaring him up
[Music]
Ben you cut it out come on Wilson trying
to help you there we
go you guys stay in here I think this
bull got really lucky and he's going to
go get more lucky whoa she said it let's
load all our stuff up and get out of
your hair okay keep us informed let us
know how it go I'll let you know I
wouldn't be doing this if I didn't love
it yeah I would have quit a long time
ago
say no to bullying
[Music]
idea look at them they're having fun hey
boys they got their little first mate
down there
happiness you guys catching anything a
farmer's
tan why don't you take the boat out
you guys got enough fish for supper I
don't I don't want to lie to you so no
no looks like you guys need to take a
little float with the dog I'm down for
that I'm jumping in too I bet you're
going to end up right there I'm going to
hang out in my hammock with a book deal
[Music]
deal
come on Winnie let's go fix you up
today's the big day to fix Winnie's
dislocated
knee go ahead and get some anesthesia
going a dislocated knee on a guinea
isn't the easiest thing in the world to
get placed back in you ready mhm we've
got to be very very careful if we pull
too hard we may break a bone you also
have to be very very strong in your
movement to get this uh pulled apart and
put back into place think she's sleepy
yeah we've got a young immature bird
under general anesthesia we've got to
move
quickly I'm going to push down you pull
the leg out and rotate it around that's
back in line is
it mhm what do you think I feel like
that doesn't look very
good maybe it got its leg caught in
something who knows here just doesn't
want to go back in in it's not going to
go look at all the Hemorrhage there
yeah there is so much swelling in and
around this joint that the joint capsule
itself is obliterated unfortunately
manipulating the joint and replacing it
is now not an option this isn't going to
[Music]
work what are we going to do I really
think that the only option that we have
is to probably amputate this leg bin do
you want to go call Todd
yeah it's like when you're trying to put
a nut on a bolt hey Todd thanks for
answering and the the threads are just
stripped I think we need to go to
amputation and try to remove this leg
and give her a chance there's no way
that that'll ever hold again so we got
to go to plan B their skin is so fragile
thinner than chicken
skin there's no way that an animal can
live with a dislocated leg leg like that
so we're going to give her a chance
we've got to move quickly because no
bird can be under anesthesia long they
get very hypothermic they could just
quit breathing whatever happened I think
there was a lot of trauma trauma and
swelling oh yeah look at all this this
is huge
Hemorrhage well that was
quick there's the leg we've got Winnie
through the hardest part okay two more
stitches and then we're done she just
needs to rest and recuperate now hey you
oh there's your eyes hi I saw you
Winnie's all done with her procedure so
now she gets to go home and recover at
the grandkids house well on a good note
She's So Young that if she can adapt to
this she's not really going to ever know
the difference you know I mean this is
going to be the story of Winnie The
[Music]
Guinea
hey boys Dr Aaron and Ben are coming
we're making a delivery here to Val's
house which is actually where I grew up
hey B hi hi boys guess what we have it's
a basketball hoop awesome brought a ball
for you here to here you go Bud wow what
do you say guys than it makes me a
little sad that chase and Charlie are
kind of on to the next phase of their
lives but I'm really happy that I can
help another mommy see her kids go out
and do all these great things we knew
you didn't have a basketball hoop here
anymore and uh Charlie and Chase have
kind of outgrown this well thank you
very much I know if they don't use it I
will yeah here you go you ready all
right oh he's got it okay let's get this
thing unloaded and get you guys shooting
just walk it up good job Conor good
job all right ready throw it through
hard
oh I used to play basketball as a kid
right in this driveway I think they're
going to like it I do too keep them busy
at least for a half an hour yeah so it's
kind of bringing back some really good
memories there it is there it is yeah
job not a boy it's where we got married
I walked under your old hoop out to meet
you with the alar honey that's right
thank you guys so much enjoy guys
Christmas in
July all right
byee use your legs jump
[Music]
high
are you going to shake oh hi sweet boy
do you shake your other foot or just
this foot oh he will when he puts it
down there you oh good
boy come on
in and you got a horse in there huh yeah
all right we'll just stop you right when
I say hold your
horses that looks great you did promise
you had a miniature horse I did
Charlie all right Charlie Horse yeah I
didn't think of that when I named
him oh he's
beautiful with Charlie as soon as me and
the dogs go out the back door he is
pulling at the gate cuz he wants in the
backyard with the dogs and he chases
them and runs with them and plays with
them he thinks he's one of the dogs come
on come on Charlie Mama's got to
treat come get it how'd you get get him
in the trailer treats yeah and I pushed
a lot usually he's full of energy and
running around he's walking really slow
he has trouble getting up oh here he
comes come on there he goes mama just
got to nudge you huh he just seemed to
be getting worse and so it was time to
bring him to the bed his feet hurt him a
little bit don't they they might it
really looks like he's turning that leg
a lot he's just not himself he's not
spunky I get the feed bucket he doesn't
run with me
you're okay
buddy good he's got a strong heart rate
now it is a little fast for a horse that
could indicate that he's in some pain
okay let's see if he's running a fever
oh Charlie he's not used to this I don't
know if anybody's used to this but yeah
got him
okay 99.9 so he's sitting right in the
middle of normal it doesn't look like we
have an infectious disease going on here
okay what I do see is a charlie horse
here that doesn't want to move his feet
it looks like they hurt get my hoof
testers out and we'll try to see if he's
sore on his feet you know when I kind of
pinch him okay especially his front feet
his front feet yeah a horse carries 60%
of its weight on the front feet okay
that's usually where they show some
tenderness or soreness now I'm going to
squeeze a little bit and see what
happens he didn't like that his right
front seems pretty painful let's SE it
on his left side I'll switch sides with
you really can I have it good boy good
boy oh that hurts that hurts okay it's
okay easy
easy I don't have to keep doing it I
know exactly what's wrong
here we're done making it hurt Charlie
thank you thank you for hanging in there
with us I know you guys haven't owned
horses before if I say laminitis does
that ring a bell I know it's a hoof
thing but I don't know exactly what it
means well it's basically inflammation
of the feet okay and I think that's what
we have here we have a hoof that when it
gets inflamed there's nowhere for that
inflammation to swell to right it's
trapped in a hoof capsule so his pain
it's like oh it's like if you hit your
nail with a hammer and you've got all
that swelling underneath your nail it
has nowhere to go I really think I know
what's going on with the inflammation
here let's get them weighed but I want
to get Charlie on the scale and just
confirm it there you go okay got one
more foot to get there
perfect holy cow holy crap 314 lb that's
way more than I thought yeah he's got to
lose about 40 to 60 lb that's a lot of
weight Charlie
Boy I can tell you why it happened is
because of his diet anything with a high
high sugar load like beautiful green
grass in the yard when they can't metab
abize all those sugars going in it makes
a crazy thing happen in their Hooves so
you don't buy a mini horse to mow your
yard nope you don't every day he gets
the long grass out of the front yard an
apple and two carrots he gets field corn
sometimes and lots of
Treats they're miniature for a reason
they need to eat a miniature diet okay
he gets fed an appropriate amount of hay
twice a day and that's what he gets to
eat I would even cut without the horse
treats okay okay I know most people
spoil their pets by giving them lots of
treats I'm guilty of it too but it can
lead to increased weight which is a big
Health concern he's not going to want to
exercise until his feet feel a little
bit better so we've got some pain
medication it's just a little tiny
tablet once a day and that will start
helping him feel better and wanting to
exercise it is kind of tough because you
want to give him what they want because
you love them so much but if it's not
healthy for them then I have to cut back
truth be told
my husband Todd gives way more treats
than I do I'm going to check in with you
guys I promise and we're going to see
how much weight we've lost okay okay I'm
going to check in on Charlie in a couple
months next time I see him hopefully
there will be less of this little
miniature horse it's the weight loss
program for you big
guy we got some new toys for you guys
here's you want this one oh yeah
you like this one
Doris
nope like that
one that one no how about this
one no are none of these toys good
enough for
you definitely not that one you're a lot
more picky than zoinks
is Hi here's Raider hi Raider how are
you Raider back today he's an aged
rescue sharpi that's here for entropion
surgery all right so there's three
little pokes Bud all right tiny poke
entropion is where the outside of the
eyelid that's all hairy is actually
rolled up under and rubbing on the
cornea or the eyeball itself all right
you get to go rest on those and then we
fix your eyes okay these eyes they are
definitely ouchy
mhm to do an entropion surgery we're
going to take out a little sliver of
tissue wherever we have rolling eyelids
we're going to take out a piece till
they go straight and then suture that
down you'll be able to see all the
kitties chase them extra fast without
surgical correction we can develop
chronic scarring and dogs can even lose
their
[Music]
sight all right you got front one two
three so Val this is probably one of the
worst cases I I think I've seen you know
he is just rolling in we're going to
take all this skin from under here out I
wanted to make him look comfortable but
not have the look of permanent
surprise the technicality of the surgery
is not tremendously difficult in all of
the different surgeries we do but it's
very very detailed it's very fine work
all right big guy so I'm putting this
clamp on here kind of makes a nice
little crimp in that tissue and he's got
so much
[Music]
tissue take a little bit more
there so I'm just cutting this tissue
away so I'm going to put in a couple
stitches and see if I like what I've
done okay I'm liking this says Ah my
eyes feel better we've got the first eye
done but now we have to do the other eye
which is actually his wor worst eye this
eye has rolling in the upper lid the
lateral canthus or the outside eyelid
and the lower lid almost makes a full
roll and a half so we've got to take a
lot of tissue out to really get this eye
so it's
comfortable just going to take all that
tissue to get that out the trick with
entropion is that if we don't take
enough tissue once they wake up the
eyelid still rolls in but if I take too
much tissue then I can give this dog
ectropion where the eyelids roll out it
can allow excess dirt and debris to get
into the eyes I hope we get this right
for him okay I'm about to do the
ouchie buddy hang in
there this is extremely severe this
rolling in of the tissue on three
different sides of his eye nope that's
still rolling so I'm going to be a
little more aggressive because I want
this to be the final fix for Raider
trying to give you a very cosmetically
lovely look here
bud I'm trying to pull back the outside
of the eyelids cuz those were even
rolling in you really have to take into
account a lot of the different forces
that play with the skin and even gravity
so it's really important to stay
focused last Stitch
fell going to make him look 20 years
younger we have so much tissue swelling
that's going to happen so what we see
while he's laying here versus what we
see in a couple weeks is all going to be
different there you
go his face looks a little rough but I
can see his eyes and even under
anesthesia you can see he's starting to
see things around him that I think he
hasn't seen in a long time because his
eyes have been too painful to open it's
a pretty neat feeling I I deep in my
heart I I know that I've helped this dog
done good
[Music]
Raider ra of the Lost
eyeballs hey Caitlyn could you help me a
minute I've got something out in the
truck sure I'll show you here it's
amazing he's even
alive oh my gosh
that is the absolute cutest baby deer
that I have ever seen I think he fell
off a cliff up at Louis and Clark Lake
he was laying down not moving very much
we had to climb up quite a ways to get
him during the early summer we get a lot
of calls about baby Wildlife being
abandoned today was a really hot day for
that fwn to be on the cliff how high do
you think the cliff was 50 60
ft my son works for the ging Parks he
climbed up the cliff and he brought it
down and we head it straight here great
news that he's even standing I noticed
his nose is pretty dry he's definitely
dehydrated why don't you look at him
give me a call absolutely we'll do thank
you I've worked with Dr abandon eron
before let's go get a fixed up bud they
were able to help me out and house these
animals temporarily until we can find a
permanent home for them through wildlife
rehab there we go let's get you some
fluids buddy and get you fed this little
deer been on the heat all day so we want
to get them rehydrated with some fluids
try to make him normal again this is
going to be our go- go bag it's going to
make you want to go
[Music]
go look at this old hot rod yeah that's
pretty cool that's very
cool hey guys hi docs today we came out
to Todd's place to check on Winnie the
guinea Winnie the onelegged guinea she's
in there somewhere is she tough to tell
apart from the other guies yeah except
she hops on one leg she has the
strongest leg in Cedar County I
bet well I'd love to see her if you want
to go in and get her
okay I got her you got her hi Winnie oh
wow bring her on out look at her wow she
looks great so have you been taking care
of her all by yourself yeah yeah can I
hold her yeah all right don't lose her
Ben I'll try not come here Winnie Aon
take a look does it look all right that
looks so good there's no scabbing oh
it's okay you did good
Winnie I tell you what I've never done
this surgery before but it looks like it
worked out yeah it did mhm I was really
surprised thank you Todd for taking the
time and bringing this little baby in
because it needed help they did thanks
you're
welcome I think Todd wins Grandpa of the
Year Todd's grandkids love their animals
and you can tell it's rubbing off on
Grandpa it's really the kids that
sometimes teach us all about humanity
and really about taking care of all
creatures great and small well you guys
Winnie looks so good I'm going to put
her back in her enclosure open up the
gate let's put her back in there I want
to see how she gets along with the rest
of
them look at
[Music]
that oh gosh
Caitlyn he's trying to run are you
trying to run away our local
conservation officer Jeff Jones got a
call about a fawn who had fallen off a
cliff Caitlyn has been triage it and now
we need to really get some nutrition in
this baby it is a little girl it's a
little dough so we can name her Jane D
look at you go Jeff didn't know if it
was injured or not but it was super
dehydrated okay he was out on the heat
for a while you got some fluids into it
yep we got fluids in we might get it
another bottle here my gosh we need to
make sure that we address hydration and
nutritional status okay do you want some
more milks is that good you want some
more this is a young animal so if we
don't keep blood glucoses up we could be
in really really hot water obviously I'm
really concerned if it fell off a cliff
that we have any sort of head trauma
fractures broken legs there's a lot of
blunt force trauma that certainly could
have happened we need to find out what
if anything is wrong with the animal can
we take a listen my
[Music]
dear Caitlyn everything sounds great
there's no crackles wheezes but now that
she's gotten some food I feel like we're
stable enough let's go do an assessment
on her let's go see if you walk okay
this was a big fall and sometimes things
take a little while to show up did you
take a big tumble and lose your mommy we
don't know if she'll be able to even
walk to the eye obviously she can stand
up but I really want to make sure we
don't have any deficits potentially even
some nerve damage something like that
from her fall so here Dango
okay
oh she looks pretty good Caitlyn she's
going about 100 miles an hour I'm
shocked to see that she's in such good
shape after having such a big fall so
when I flip her foot onto the back she
should pick it up and recognize that's
not the way to place her foot Jane do is
able to walk she can place her feet her
eyes are bright and clear she's making
Little Fawn
noises if I were to have put bets on how
healthy this animal would be I would
have lost
eron I just got a text from Jeff Jones
this is the
deer she's the cutest thing ever what is
it about these little baby fawns that
just gets you right here I don't
know don't you think we just need to
take an x-ray just to make sure that
everything looks okay yeah I think that
wouldn't be a bad idea just to make sure
we don't have anything that we might be
missing or any free fluid in our abdomen
or her chest just to be sure yeah Jane
looks good right now but anytime we we
have massive trauma we can have slow
bleeders in the brain we can have
cranial swelling it's just like if a
person hits their head sometimes they
look normal at first and a few hours
later they have seizures they're in a
coma or it becomes an extreme
emergency looks like she might have a
little tiny contusion where do you see
it just right here oh
yeah her long doesn't seem to be
allowing as much air as it should right
in that area because of the big bruise
back here it's fine but up here it's a
little bit worrisome little baby Jane is
a wild animal and they are the best at
hiding their injuries from humans that's
what they're designed to do is hide
those injuries so that we don't know
that they're hurt I think the best thing
to do is just keep her calm monitor her
oxygen a little bit here and there and
just make sure that she looks like she's
not panting because that could be from
lack of oxygen we can be dear Mom for a
day or two but really this is going to
take a pretty big team to keep Jane do
moving forward and living her best life
you lay down sweet
[Music]
girl
hi doc Ben hi guys thanks for coming out
you bet you how are you doing good doing
good good to see you how is Charlie
doing he's doing so much better lot
happier running around a little more
Mary and Todd invited me here today to
recheck Charlie look him over and make
sure that he's lost some weight he was
not good there for a while was he he was
not he was well over 300 lb last time we
weighed him right food is love right
what are you feeding him now manyi horse
speed and AA so basically you've lowered
the carbohydrates and up the protein yep
I want to see Charlie I kind of miss him
and I actually grabbed the scale from
the front of the clinic and we're going
to go ahead and reway him and just see
how his weight is doing you mind helping
me get the scale you bet all right last
time I saw Charlie he had laminitis or
founder and his feet were growing out
the more weight that Charlie can lose
the better off his feet are going to
feel there he is there you go Charlie
Good Boy watch your hands
last time we weighed him he weighed 315
[Music]
lbs look at that Charlie
286 lb he's lost 30 lb yep that's
incredible you guys you know I can tell
he starting to get his waist he looks
great that's good boy Charlie see this
really brings some relief to me because
I was pretty worried about Charlie he
was overweight his feet weren't right I
really think that Mary and Todd did a
great job of helping him lose that
weight all right you guys my work here
is done thanks a lot you
bet come here rid hi Raider you guys are
here to see the doctors for a recheck
yes do a checkup go right in okay thank
you it's been a month since Raider's eye
surgery so today he's coming in for a
recheck I'm so excited to see him and
hopefully he's excited to see me too hey
Raider hi
look at you you have eyeballs definitely
seems a lot more
active yes he is he runs around more and
he explores a little
more I love watching Rider run around it
makes me so happy he's just living life
unfazed exploring doing his thing and
that makes all of us so happy yeah he
looks really good I mean there's like
legit eyes in there yeah so much better
there we go the first time we saw him he
just came in and he kind of kept his
head low and didn't really interact so
I'm absolutely thrilled I feel like he
really is a different dog that's all we
want buddy I think you hit the the new
home lottery here all right well thank
you so much for bringing him in today
you did good pup thank you
[Music]
yep take your kids to workday I love it
the boys are here with us today today
and I think they're going to be pretty
pleasantly surprised with what's going
on come on down guys we have something
to show you we're going on a field
trip it's going to be way worth getting
out of bed guys they're going to take a
little trip with us so we get something
up Our Sleeve Jane you ready to go to
your new
home wow you got some energy today this
Little Fawn made an amazing recovery
she's completely healed up from her
chest contusion she's oxygenating
normally it makes me feel happy to do
what I do this is one of those mornings
look at here guys hey that oh my God
isn't she cute oh yeah yeah this is Jane
Doe Jeff Jones brought her in she was
really dehydrated but she was super
lucky there's nothing wrong with her
today's the day she gets to go to her
forever home yep we're going to take her
down to a rehab center near Omaha so um
where's this Jane do riding she's going
to sit between you guys here you go you
better practice holding her oh my God
she kind of tries to jump she's a little
like a bunny all right you guys let's
get loaded up we have a 3-hour trip
ahead of us here's hoping that little
Jane Doe can find a new family really
start growing and living her life seat
belts on
[Music]
yep
we're here
guys we made it yeah hi welcome to the
safari park thank you very much uh here
you brought a package for us we did yeah
we have a 3- week old Fawn roughly we
rehydrated her we've been feeding her
but we heard you guys have a small deer
herd and that you'd probably be willing
to try cross fostering her and getting
her a mom absolutely yeah they always do
better uh without hand raising them we
have a herd of three female with six
fawns so they all had twins they can
easily take on more so I think it'll
work out real well excellent fingers
crossed this works fingers crossed so
what hopefully takes place here our
little baby Jane can come over and start
nursing that's really the B the first
Bond or the first touch that needs to
happen and from there sometimes nature
just takes its course how do you propose
we introduce Jane do here to your herd
and to your M's I have one of them
locked kind of inside the barn and an
outside Corral we brought some treats to
keep Mama occupied and so she can slowly
realize what we're doing sometimes it
takes a little bit but as long as we do
it slow it'll be one big happy family
they'll live happily ever after yeah
well it's worth a shot boys you ready to
bring Jane do out yep that's really a
pretty intimate moment between uh a
mother and a baby and a lot of moms say
no no no that's not your food source and
you go away and find your own mom and
here she is she looks very healthy she's
beautiful yeah well let's head in okay
nursing is really the crucial moment for
this bond to happen so if that happens I
feel like we're well on our
way there she goes that's the wrong end
she has to relearn it a little bit
doesn't
she did you find
it she figured it out yes I think she
got a taste scary oh yeah I do too she's
like no where did my mom go I've seen
this work in other species but never a
wh tailed deer you know what guys I
think Jane found her home this is
awesome I feel like we just hit a home
run this is a home run a touchdown a
goal all at once this would give maybe
them a great chance to see if they can
sort of solidify that Bond so let's just
give them some time alone sounds good
hit me in the heartstrings I've got my
kids here yay there's just something
special about seeing that bond between a
mother animal and their baby this deer
just said you're my baby now I think
that's pretty cool
[Music]
mhm